[Music]
i would like to thank the
organizer for inviting me to give a talk
so today my talk is on the interplay
between
dengue morphological diversity and
antibody recognition
so my name is she may lock and i'm from
duke and u.s
medical school and i'm also from
nus
so dengue virus i'm kind of sure
all of you know uh what it is you know
we have this
outbreak every year and this year is one
of the worst
um so it is a positive sense rna virus
and there are four serotypes dengue one
to 4
it causes disease ranging from the mild
dengue fever to the more severe dengue
hemorrhagic fever
so the more dengue fever is
characterized by biphysic
fever rash muscles and joint pain
the more severe dengue hemorrhagic fever
has the same symptoms
as in the maldengi fever in addition you
get
hemorrhagic manifestation and plasma
leakage
so there are no highly effective vaccine
or therapeutics available
so um this is just to show you how
dengue is transmitted dengue cannot be
transmitted between humans
it needs to go through a mosquito vector
and i would like to point
out that the mosquito their body
temperature equilibrates to the room
temperature
and human physiological temperature is
that
around 37 degrees celsius
so this is a dengue virus infection
cycle so the mature virus binds to a
series or receptor
and then it gets endocytose the low ph
in the anuser
causes the e protein of the virus to
change from dimer to monomer and then
primaric stage to to allow fusion
between the virus and the
endosymbol membrane and this releases
the genomic rna into the cell cytoplasm
and then the protein is translated from
this
rna genome and then you have viral
replication
the virus is assembled in the
endoplasmic reticulum here
at nutriph as you can see the surface of
the virus
is spikey it's very different compared
to the materials
and on top of this immature virus
there's an extra protein called prm
and so the virus matured through the
transgolgi network and as you can see
the
transcodging network the ph drops as as
you go
and this actually stimulates the virus
surface to reorganize
into dimers just like the mature virus
and on top of this you have this prn
so this is in cyan color here and
um during this maturation furine
cleave the prm and but the pr stays on
top of the virus
and only when it is released when the ph
increases the affinity of the pr drops
and then the pr follow up the virus
making the mature
fully mature virus particle
so on the surface of dengue virus the
major protein is the e
protein it is also the major antigenic
structure
which is targeted by antibodies so this
is the crystal structure
of the e protein it exists as thymus
this is one proton and that's the other
proton
and um each proton is divided into three
domains
domain one the main two in the main
so e protein is important for entry of
the virus
into the cell involving receptor binding
and fusion to the endosymbol membrane
so this is the crystal structure of pr
and e complex
uh of on the immature virus so you have
the e protein again
but on top of this you have the pr and
actually you have the pr
on the in the crystal structure the m
part is actually very floppy so you do
not see the density
so the pr actually caps the fusion loop
of the e protein
the importance of this pr is
um on the immutable virus is it
it prevents the virus from fusing back
into the cell
so remember this is the maturation
process so
the ph here in the transcoding network
is very similar to the endosome
so if you do not have a pr cap on the
fusion loop the virus will fuse back
so the function of the prm is to prevent
this from happening so you have a
productive
infectivity and
okay so however this maturation process
here
is not very um
efficient so when you prepare metro
virus
in in in tissue culture you always get a
mixture of mature virus
partially mature and immature virus so
in this microbial
the very raw particles are the fully
mature virus and then the very spiky
ones are the
fully immature virus and then on top of
that you have
um
so that means you know when the virus
infects cells
it will secrete viruses in
mature and then the partially immature
or you can call it partially mature so
actually all these viruses are
infectious but
you know they because the structure is
very different they have very different
antigenic characteristics
so on top of that um it
gets even more complicated we discover
that the mature virus
actually can also change in a structure
so this is the warm dengue virus mature
structure
so we saw on um so we tested
my lab and also michael rossmann's
laboratory
we are separately observed that
the laboratory dengue virus two strains
when you grow them in mosquito cells at
28 degrees they appear around and
compact but when you heat it up to 37
degrees the virus becomes
bumpy um something like that and
so we try to solve the structure there
are really four structural classes but i
only show you
so at 28 degrees celsius the smooth
complex structure the e protein
organized in a very tight way so
there are three e-dimers they interact
with each other and lie
terror to each other forming a rough and
there are 30 of such rough
organized in the hearing bone pattern so
when you heat it up today seven degrees
celsius
the e protein moves outwards and there
are less
interaction between the e proteins and
the surface becomes
much more much more looser
okay and we we would like to know
whether this structural change
also happened to the dengue clinical
isolate and so we look at four of them
and all of them actually at 37 degrees
celsius this seems to be
much more stable than the um then the
laboratory strains are three out of four
stays
round and compact only one becomes bumpy
surface
and the interesting thing is these two
um
are from the same outbreak so what we
think
could be happening is um the virus is
actually in fact the people first with
the round compact structure
and then but in order to survive or
escape from the immune system
they actually change a structure into
the bumpy surface
so um but for all clinical strains at 40
degrees they all become
bumpy so what is the implication for
vaccine and therapeutic
development so for vaccine right you are
supposed to use this to train
the people to the immune system to
recognize
uh infecting virus so when the person is
first inspected they probably will see
a virus at 37 degrees celsius so
that means that for a vaccine you should
include both
smooth surface particle and bobby
surface particle
so how about prophylactic and
therapeutic antibody
so for prophylactic antibody usually you
use it
so for example a visitor from the u.s
comes here and they know there's a
dengue outbreak they won't act to
protect
themselves against the dengue virus so
they would inject themselves with an
antibody and and then when they come
here if they get infected they will
encounter virus at the
37 degrees celsius so the
prophylactic antibody mixture cocktail
should have
those antibody that is good for the
smooth
particle and also effective against the
bumpy particles so that will be a
mixture well so for therapeutic antibody
you use it only when the person
is uh infected
and and people the patients are usually
admitted in the hospital
when they are having a fever so the
virus
will likely all become bumpy and
therefore you should use the antibody
that are effective against the bumpy
surface project
okay and then on top of this we found
another new morphology that's the club
shaped structure
and so this is the dengue three cup
shape
morphology and so this is a
four degrees uh
structure so when when we grow them in
mosquito saline and purify them
so you have mature virus and then uh
immature virus and then when we heat
them up to 29 degrees
and 37 degrees we see that the mature
the partially mature becomes the club
shaped
uh structure here and we also did a test
where we incubate
the this prep in different temperatures
for 30 minutes
and then you see a gradual gradual
increase of the
percentage of uh club shaped particles
and um at 20 at 37 degrees celsius
there are approximately 20 percent of
the particles forming club shaped
particles
and and further increase in temperature
will not increase
any more of the number of cup shaped
particles
so and we did an asymmetric
reconstruction of these club chip
particles
so this is the um view that
the this is the cup head and this is the
tail
and then when you turn it to side view
you can see that
the heat is actually flat it's not round
okay and then
so this is the zika virus we see some
cuphead
and then this is a dengue one so this is
the cup shaped particles and you can see
the tail is much thinner
and then dengue two um you can also see
some here
and uh new guinea this is a
clinical isolate this is a laboratory
strain and west paxo
you do see them but they are in smaller
numbers
so um what i want to say is
this shows that the virus has the
capability of
to change into club-shaped particles if
they want to
so and then we also look at how they
bind to
different antibodies so this is the
control again and when we add a fusion
loop antibody
fat for g2 you can see it binds to the
head only and not the tail
and therefore this then it this domain
three antibody a9
it binds to the head and the tip of the
tail
so that means there are different
binding to different parts of the club
shaped structure
so it is possible there are part of it
that cannot be bound and so they can
infect the cells
as phenomenal
okay and then we tested it um
with a e protein dimer binding antibody
so this fat c10 it binds across the 2e
protein proteome within a dimer and it
looks like it binds to both the head and
the tail
and
the fat uh then increasing the
temperature to stimulate
crop shape particles with vision
and physique when this happens
virus also becomes the club shaped
particles but when you add this
antibody instead of becoming a clutcher
it becomes a caterpillar structure
so um for this dengue 3 we
box the tail of the uh
club shape particle and then you can see
this is a 2d
average the fab actually uh
you can see the fat very clearly and
then the diffraction of this um
tail shows layer lines uh indicating
that
it has a helical structure so for zika
virus right
this is the cathode shape we average
them you can see clearly the fab
structure
and also the layer lines
suggesting that they also have a helical
structure
so we solved the structure so this is
the tail of the c10 clock shaped
particles this is the cryo-em structure
here
and the dark blue is the fat and then
this this thing here is the
dimer um and this is the caterpillar
okay and then to interpret the map we
actually put in the e protein
and the fat molecules so these are the
this is the
b protein with the fat here and this
is the e protein so you know um we have
done some studies before
and we know that actually this c10 uh
when it binds to zika in
it can bind uh across uh the
two e protein protons within a dimer but
it also
binds across e protein dimers here
so it's able to lock the rough but to
dengue 3 is unable to lock the
the uh the rough so
it only binds to the e protein protons
within the dimer but not across timers
okay so that's why the structure of the
setup complex with magnitude and musica
is so different
okay so how does it organize from the
spherical structure
into this structures so again uh this is
the
dengue or zika around particle
organization this is one e protein raw
so i'm showing you two e protein right
here one here
and then the next is this one here okay
so this one is in red here
and then the blue is the neighboring
rough okay for the zika virus
fat caterpillar structure these two
rafts
actually uh rotate
and then then it sort of form a helical
structure here
and actually this uh intradimer
interaction oops sorry enter diamond
interaction
is the same as this internal interaction
here
okay and um how about the dengue virus
three fab club ship structure so the
first
movement is also the same as the zika
caterpillar structure
these two rough they moved here first
but because this fab is unable to lock
between dimers the dimers were able
to slide away from each other so forming
the tail part
so does the presentation of different
morphologies confer
advantages to the survival of virus
i i would think so because
the e protein is organized in a
completely different way
between all these structures so like
antibody that is very good
in binding to the e protein diamonds is
unable to bind here because e protein is
not organized as diamonds
here and for here the e protein diamonds
may have separated
you know and and the cup shape has a
different structure
so
[Music]
we we should study all this virus
morphology because they are all
infectious
and we can't ignore them so for the
mature compact virus
they're very infectious they infect
cells they're binding to attachment
factors such as harpoon sulfate
timber and dc signed and they may or may
not bind to a specific receptor
the mature expanded virus structure is
just as infectious as the mature compact
structure
so for the immature virus um it infects
in a different way
so by itself is non-infectious but it
can
in fact fc receptor positive cells when
the virus is complex with anti-prm
certain nte proteins certain
nte antibodies and also dc sign
so the partially mature virus can enter
cells
by pathways utilized by both the fully
mature
and immature virus so for the club
shaped particles because only
20 percent change in the purpose is very
hard to measure if there are still
infections but what we know is
the club-shaped particles contains rna
genome
and there's no detectable reduction in
the amount of virus attached to cells
after club ship formation
okay so then i went on to analyze um
so we have a lot of structural
information of uh
dengue neutralizing antibodies and where
they find
and just by looking at the level of
accessibility of their aptitude we can
kind of guess how
whether the antibodies can bind to the
different
dengue virus morphology so these are
different color codes
from the least accessible to the most
accessible
in green so you can see for dengue
three antibodies only the mature
expanded particles
uh their epitopes are fully accessible
the rest are not so
for the fusion loop only the immature
virus
and and the rest are not really that
good
um domain one antibody seems like
is accessible in all kinds of morphology
and then there are a virus quaternary
dependent epitope
uh antibodies they're highly
neutralizing
against a mature compact so they bind
either across dimers uh
they usually buy across e-protein dimers
so only the mature they can only bind to
the mature compact virus but
um but and it's very poor against the
other
uh virus morphology and so
um the e-protein dimer binding
antibodies
they are probably able to bind the
mature compact mature expanded
and the club-shaped particles well but
not not the rest
okay so for antibody therapeutics
and vaccine development is there an
antibody
so if you were to only use one antibody
for therapeutics and prophylactic
is there one that could neutralize all
stereotypes and
also all morphologies mixture for
prophylactic and therapeutic development
and for vaccine maybe we should include
all this morphology
in order to protect everyone from
all different kinds of shapes of the
dengue
virus particle
okay so and this is the last slide the
acknowledgement slide so
all these books have been done like over
the past 11 years
and many people from my lab is involved
and i would
like to especially thanks gunther
and my collaborators so jim
crow uh actually you know provided
most of the antibody and i also
um get antibodies from davide corti
and uh gavin sweden and these are the
grand agencies that i would like to
thank
i hope you guys learned about the
difficulties
in dengue vaccine and therapeutic
development
thank you for your attention